listen to this influencer on Tik Tok
talk about her own experiences as a
surrogate I've been a surrogate three
times so here is my five things I would
not do as a surrogate or trying to
become one I would not transfer more
embryos than I'm willing to carry that
means I would not transfer two or three
embryos if I only wanted to carry one
baby and not have twins or triplets I
would not bend on inner requirements in
the beginning um if you use an agency or
whatever you match with people of like
mind so you can say I don't want to work
with these type of people or I do want
to work with these typ people and here
are my requirements so if you are not
100% comfortable 100% comfortable
aborting or terminating a pregnancy
because the child might have Down
syndrome or something of that nature
it's such a review a surrogate
contractually signs her uterus over to a
third party that third party can
contractually require her to kill the
child in her womb the third party
controls what she says about her
pregnancy and then when the nine months
are up she delivers the child and hands
him over to the third party never to see
him again